Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
OUR CAKES ARE THE FUTURE
OF THE WEDDING CAKE.
HOW CLEVER THAT IS.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHEN YOU WALKED IN HERE,
I THOUGHT,
"CHA-CHING-A-LING-A-DING-DONG."
I THINK
YOU'RE ONTO SOMETHING.
YOU'LL PAY FOR YOUR COLLEGE
IF THIS WORKS.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
YOU COULD TALK A DOG OFF
A MEAT WAGON, I'M TELLING YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE 35K.
I WANT TO BE A 50/50 PARTNER.
I DON'T INVEST
IN RICH KIDS' BUSINESSES.
DON'T SCREW IT UP.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I'M SO CLOSE TO
GETTING OVER THE HILL ON THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S A BUNCH OF CRAP.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN A PIMPLE
ON A TEENAGER. YOU'RE NOTHING.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
ARE MOTHER-AND-SON ENTREPRENEURS
WITH A NEW TWIST
ON A WEDDING TRADITION.
HI.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY AYA.
AND I'M HER SON KORAY, AND WE'RE
FROM GRAND RAPIDS, MICHIGAN,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS FUNCAKES.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR $285,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 25% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERY BRIDE
DESERVES TO HAVE A GORGEOUS CAKE
AT HER WEDDING.
BUT THOSE SKY-HIGH TIERS,
INTRICATE DESIGNS,
SUGAR FLOWERS -- THEY ALL COME
AT A STEEP COST.
THE PRICE OF WEDDINGS
HAS GOTTEN OUT OF HAND,
ESPECIALLY
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY.
SO BRIDES ON A BUDGET --
THEY COME TO US
BECAUSE WE DELIVER IT ALL BUT
ONLY AT A SLICE OF THE PRICE.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT,
WE HAVE A NEW AND UNIQUE CAKE.
IT HAS ZERO CALORIES.
IT IS GLUTEN-FREE,
SUGAR-FREE, LACTOSE-FREE,
AND IT HAS A SHELF LIFE
OF 7-PLUS YEARS.
SO, YOU MAY ASK,
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
WELL, OUR CAKES...
ARE MADE OF FOAM.
Corcoran: [ Laughing ] OH!
AND THEY'RE RENTALS.
GREAT FOOLER.
WOW.
OUR CAKES ARE COVERED
IN REAL FONDANT AND GUM PASTE,
EXACTLY THE SAME AS A REAL CAKE.
THE ONLY THING DIFFERENT
IS THE INSIDE IS FOAM.
EACH CAKE HAS
A SECRET COMPARTMENT IN THE BACK
WHERE REAL CAKE
CAN BE PLACED.
THIS WAY, THE BRIDE AND GROOM
CAN STILL CUT THE CAKE,
FEED EACH OTHER,
GET ALL THEIR PHOTOS.
THEN THE CAKE
IS WHEELED TO THE BACK,
AND SHEET CAKES
ARE SERVED TO THEIR GUESTS.
NO ONE IS THE WISER.
HOW CLEVER THAT IS.
WE SEE THIS AS THE FUTURE
OF THE WEDDING CAKE.
WE HOPE TO KEEP THE TRADITION
OF THE WEDDING CAKE ALIVE,
BUT AT A PRICE
COUPLES CAN AFFORD.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WANTS
TO JOIN THE FUN WITH FUNCAKES?
OUR CAKES MAY BE FAKE,
BUT OUR MONEY IS REAL.
THE IDEA'S BRILLIANT.
THANK YOU.
ONE -- ARE THERE
OTHER PEOPLE DOING IT?
NO.
NOBODY ELSE?
THERE ARE A FEW PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COPIED US, BUT NOBODY SHIPS.
WE SHIP OUR CAKES
WORLDWIDE.
AND THEY SHIP THEM
BACK TO YOU AFTER?
CORRECT.
CAN YOU SHIP A CAKE
THAT BIG,
OR DOES SOMEBODY
HAVE TO ASSEMBLE IT?
NO. YOU OPEN UP THE BOX,
AND IT'S READY TO GO.
THERE'S ONE EDIBLE SECTION
IN THE BACK.
THREE TWINKIES
AND A CAN OF FROSTING
IS ALL THEY NEED
TO FILL THAT.
THREE TWINKIES?
SO, HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING THIS?
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
SEVEN YEARS.
WE HAVE OVER $5 MILLION
IN PUBLICITY WITH OUR COMPANY.
SO, THE MAGIC QUESTION --
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
I'VE TALKED ENOUGH.
THIS YEAR,
WE'VE DONE $150,000 IN SALES.
THAT'S IT?
WE DID A GROSS PROFIT
OF $76,000.
$150,000 IN SALES
AFTER 7 YEARS?
WE JUST LEARNED
SOMETHING HERE.
AFTER SEVEN YEARS,
IT'S CLEAR TO ME
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT
A FAKE CAKE AT THEIR WEDDING.
EXACT OPPOSITE.
SEE, BUT
IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
AFTER SEVEN YEARS, WHAT WE HAVE
BUILT IS AN IDEA AND A BRAND.
YOU HAVEN'T BUILT ANYTHING.
IN THE WEDDING INDUSTRY,
YOU'RE NOT EVEN A PIMPLE
ON A TEENAGER. YOU'RE NOTHING.
FOR RIGHT NOW.
AND THE BIG THING
HAS BEEN --
SEVEN YEARS.
YOU'RE SEVEN YEARS IN.
RIGHT.
Koray: I MEAN, WHEN WE GOT ON
THE "TODAY" SHOW,
IT WAS MORE ABOUT,
"LOOK AT THESE CRAZY PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE THIS OBSCENE IDEA
TO RENT CAKES."
WHO CARES? YOU KEEP GOING BACK
TO THE PUBLICITY.
YOU SEEM
VERY PROUD OF THAT.
I'M JUST EXPLAINING
THAT WE'VE HAD THAT.
BUT YOU SEEM
VERY PROUD OF IT.
OH, OF COURSE I AM.
AND IT'S TURNED INTO NOTHING.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
BELIEVE ME, WE WOULDN'T
COME IN FRONT OF YOU
WITH SUCH A FABULOUS IDEA
AND ONLY $150,000 IN SALES...
O'Leary: OKAY, KIMBERLY.
...AND EXPECT YOU TO --
LET ME ASK A QUESTION.
GO AHEAD, FINISH.
WHAT'S GONNA CHANGE?
WHAT IS MISSING?
LET HER FINISH.
Kimberly: SO, WE HAVE A SET
OF 200 GROCERY STORES IN CHICAGO
THAT ARE SIGNING UP WITH US.
Greiner: WHICH ONE?
JEWEL-OSCO. AND, SO, THEY'RE
GONNA BE CARRYING OUR CAKES.
THEY'RE GONNA SELL THEM
AND MATCH THEM
WITH THEIR SHEET CAKES.
SO, A BRIDE
CAN NOW COME IN,
GET A THREE-TIERED, FAKE CAKE,
TWO SHEET CAKES --
ABOUT 200 BUCKS,
SHE'S SET TO GO.
KORAY, WE NEVER EVEN ASKED
HOW MUCH THEY ARE
COMPARED TO REAL CAKES.
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE RENTAL?
SAY THE BROOCH ONE.
THAT'S A THREE-TIERED CAKE.
Herjavec:
HOW MUCH IS THAT TO RENT?
$150 WOULD BE
THE OVERALL RENTAL.
WHAT WOULD THAT CAKE COST
IF IT WAS REAL?
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
$1,200 TO MAKE THAT.
REALLY?
Corcoran: AMAZING.
Cuban: HOW LONG DOES
THE WEDDING PARTY GET TO KEEP IT
BEFORE THEY HAVE TO
SEND IT BACK?
Herjavec:
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
THEY SHIP IT BACK ON MONDAY
AFTER THE WEDDING.
YOUR TURNAROUND
IS LESS THAN A WEEK.
Koray: YEP.
OKAY. AND, SO,
HOW MANY DIFFERENT CAKES
DO YOU HAVE IN INVENTORY?
ABOUT 150.
OUT OF THE 150, HOW MANY
MAKE UP THE BULK OF THE REVENUE?
Kimberly: PROBABLY HALF.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT --
IT'S THE GROCERY STORES.
O'Leary: STAYING ON THE NUMBERS
FOR A MINUTE,
YOU'RE TELLING ME IF I GIVE YOU
$285,000, I GET 25%.
THAT'S A $1.1 MILLION VALUE
FOR A FAKE, FOAM CAKE.
YES, SIR.
THAT IS THE NORM
IN JAPAN.
Herjavec:
YOU KNOW, MOST SMALL BUSINESSES
GET SOLD BASED ON
THEIR EARNINGS.
MOST SMALL BUSINESSES
DON'T GET SOLD TIMES REVENUE.
ESPECIALLY NOT SEVEN YEARS IN.
YOU'RE NOT AN I --
YOU'RE NOT AN I.P. COMPANY.
YOU DON'T OWN
ANY INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
WHAT ARE YOUR EARNINGS?
ON $150,000...
THEY SAID.
...WHAT DID YOU MAKE LAST YEAR?
NO, THEY DIDN'T.
$76,000
WAS OUR GROSS PROFIT.
WE PAID OURSELVES
A NET INCOME OF $17,000.
SO, YOU MADE $17,000
ON $150,000.
YES.
MM-HMM.
YEP.
Greiner: LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, FAKE AND CAKE
SHOULD NOT GO TOGETHER --
FOR ME.
I WANT REAL CAKE.
THE OTHER THING IS...
YOU ARE HAVING REAL CAKE
IN SHEET CAKE.
...AT A WEDDING...
...I DON'T WANT MY "SOMETHING
BORROWED" TO BE MY CAKE.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
GUYS, I THINK
IT'S A BRILLIANT PRODUCT.
YOU GUYS HAVE 150 CAKES
IN INVENTORY.
THAT MEANS
YOU HAVE THE POTENTIAL
EVERY WEEKEND
TO MAKE $22,000,
50 WEEKS A YEAR, A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR MINIMUM,
AND YOU GUYS DID
10% OF THAT AT MOST.
YOU GUYS
ARE NOT GRINDERS.
AREN'T OUT THERE
MAKING THIS
EVERYTHING THAT CONSUMES YOU.
I'M OUT.
NOW THAT I UNDERSTAND
YOUR REVENUE,
LET ME MAKE AN OBSERVATION.
PEOPLE THAT ARE
GETTING MARRIED,
HOPING TO STAY IN LOVE
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME,
DON'T WANT A FAKE CAKE.
WHAT THIS DOES
IS ACTUALLY CAUSES DIVORCE.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
[ GASPS ]
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, THE ISSUE --
I THINK WHEN YOU TELL
YOUR BRIDE, OR VICE VERSA,
"HONEY, THIS CAKE IS FAKE
JUST LIKE OUR LOVE."
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THAT'S WHY --
THAT'S WHY THIS ISN'T WORKING.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE NOT
RENTING THESE FAKE CAKES --
BECAUSE YOU
ARE AGAINST LOVE...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...NOT JUST MONEY.
AND SO, FOR THE SAKE OF
ALL OF THE MARRIAGES COMING UP,
I'M OUT
WITH EXTREME PREJUDICE.
Herjavec: LOOK, I --
HERE'S THE FIRST THING
YOU GUYS NEED TO DO IF YOU'RE
GONNA STAY IN BUSINESS --
YOU NEED SOMEBODY ON YOUR TEAM
WHO KNOWS NUMBERS.
YOUR GRASP OF THE FINANCIAL PART
OF THE BUSINESS
IS -- IS REALLY LOOSE.
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW
YOUR NUMBERS, YOU'RE...
YOU'RE JUST ON YOUR WAY
TO BANKRUPTCY,
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT.
UH, I'M OUT.
IS ANYBODY LEFT?
SO, BARBARA,
THAT ONLY LEAVES YOU.
I HAPPEN TO THINK
YOUR IDEA IS EXTREMELY CLEVER,
AND NEEDED, BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU.
I WAS SHOCKED
TO HEAR THE COST...
DEFINITELY.
...OF A WEDDING CAKE.
AND I WAS ABOUT
TO LEAVE MY SECOND HUSBAND
AND BE REMARRIED,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA DO IT
BECAUSE THE CAKES
ARE TOO EXPENSIVE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT THERE'S TWO PARTS
TO EVERY BUSINESS.
IT'S THE BUSINESS
AND THE ENTREPRENEUR.
I THINK IT'S A CLEVER IDEA.
THAT BEING SAID, I CAN'T BELIEVE
THE TWO OF YOU WORKED LAST YEAR
FOR $17,000 COMBINED.
WHAT ARE YOU, NUTS?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
I THINK THAT
WE SEE THE FUTURE IN IT.
AND BECAUSE
WE HAD GONE TO --
AFTER 7 YEARS, $17,000.
YOU'RE FINALLY SEEING THE FUTURE
AFTER SEVEN YEARS.
THAT DOESN'T SAY TO ME,
"I'VE GOT ENTREPRENEURS
THAT ARE HUNGRY TO RUN."
I DON'T TRUST YOU,
THAT YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT
TO THE FINISH LINE.
JUST TO SHOW THAT WE'RE
WILLING TO CHANGE, WE'RE
WILLING TO LEARN --
DONE. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
NOT A BUSINESS, IT'S A HOBBY.
Kimberly:
IT'S BEEN SEVEN YEARS.
WE'RE USED TO
PEOPLE NOT GETTING IT.
BUT ONCE THEY GET IT,
THEY LOVE IT.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
CAN PUT YOU DOWN,
BUT AS AN ENTREPRENEUR,
YOU GOT TO KEEP PUSHING BACK UP
AND KEEP GOING.
"HONEY, I LOVE YOU. HERE'S
THE LITTLE SECRET DOOR
WITH THE TWINKIE IN IT."
LOOK, ANY WAY YOU SLICE IT,
THE PROBLEM
WASN'T THE BUSINESS,
IT WAS THE ENTREPRENEURS.
OH, I THINK
THE BUSINESS SUCKS, TOO.
I'M NOAH,
AND THIS IS MY DAD, BRIAN.
Brian: AND WE'RE FROM
HIGHLAND, UTAH.
DON'T FALL IN.
WHOA!
NOAH HAS BEEN
MY ACTIVITY BUDDY
SINCE HE WAS PROBABLY
2 YEARS OLD.
AND NOW WE DO
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
WE SHOULD PUT ONE MORE MATTRESS
OUT HERE.
WHEN I WAS LITTLE,
I USED TO LOVE
PLAYING WITH ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT TOYS.
THE BEST ONES
WERE THE ONES I MADE MYSELF.
WHEN YOU THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX,
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
THIS CASTLE
IS GOING TO BE MINE!
ONLY 200 MORE.
THAT'S IT?
WE'RE GONNA SELL
MORE THAN THAT.
Brian: WHEN NOAH WAS BORN,
I WAS GETTING MY MBA,
BUT HAVING A YOUNG KID,
I FELT LIKE
I HAD TO TAKE THE SECURE PATH.
NOW THAT NOAH'S OLDER,
IT SEEMED LIKE A GOOD TIME
TO START A BUSINESS TOGETHER,
AND WE BOTH CAN ENJOY IT.
I'M A 13-YEAR-OLD KID,
AND IT'S HARD
TO WALK INTO A STORE AND
ASK SOMEONE TO SELL MY PRODUCT.
WITH A SHARK BY MY SIDE,
PEOPLE WILL INSTANTLY WANT
TO HEAR ABOUT THIS PRODUCT.
I'VE TAKEN NOAH
AS FAR AS I CAN.
WHAT WE NEED
IS AN INVESTMENT FROM THE SHARK
THAT CAN SHOW HIM WHAT TO DO
TO GET HIS BUSINESS
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS NOAH,
AND I'M THE C.E.O.
OF PAPER BOX PILOTS.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M BRIAN,
AND THIS IS MILO.
HE'S OUR C.F.O.
YES, MR. WONDERFUL,
THAT'S "CHIEF FUN OFFICER."
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE ARE SEEKING $35,000
FOR A 25% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
AS A DAD,
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH MY BOYS.
AND WHAT BETTER WAY THAN
BUILDING A BUSINESS TOGETHER?
ALL KIDS LOVE TO PLAY
IN CARDBOARD BOXES.
Corcoran: MM-HMM.
AS PARENTS, YOU'VE PROBABLY
EXPERIENCED THAT TIME
WHERE YOU BOUGHT A TOY
FOR YOUR KID
ONLY TO HAVE IT LEFT BEHIND
FOR THE BOX THAT IT CAME IN.
ALWAYS.
WHEN I WAS LITTLE,
MY DAD AND I
USED TO BUILD
THE COOLEST BOX AIRPLANES.
AT 5 YEARS OLD,
I FELT LIKE I WAS A REAL PILOT.
SINCE WE ENJOYED THIS ACTIVITY
SO MUCH,
WE KNEW OTHER KIDS
WOULD LOVE TO DO IT, TOO.
SO LAST SUMMER,
MY LITTLE BROTHER, MILO, AND I
STARTED TO DESIGN
OUR PRODUCT TOGETHER.
PAPER BOX PILOTS
SELLS STICKER KITS
THAT TURN A PLAIN, OLD BOX
INTO AMAZING-LOOKING VEHICLES.
OUR STICKER KITS
PROVIDE HOURS OF CREATIVE PLAY
THAT KIDS NEED
AND MOMS LOVE.
NOAH'S BROUGHT IN
SOME SAMPLES OF HIS PRODUCT
SO HE COULD
SHARE IT WITH YOU
AND TRY STICKING THE STICKERS
FOR YOURSELF.
NICE, NOAH.
YOU'RE SELLING THE BOX
AND THE STICKERS?
WE ACTUALLY ONLY SELL
THE STICKER KITS.
SO, WAIT. SO I UNDERSTAND,
YOU ARE NOT SELLING THE BOXES.
I COULDN'T GO TO A WEBSITE
AND, FOR MY SON JAKE,
GET, LIKE, A PRE-CONFIGURED,
PRE-FOLDED, PRE-EVERYTHING.
THAT'S ACTUALLY
OUR DIFFERENTIATOR.
SO, THERE ARE
OTHER COMPETITORS
THAT DO TRY TO SELL
THE PRE-FOLDED BOXES,
AND THAT'S NOT US.
WE'VE GOT A SPECIAL --
WHAT'S NICE, THOUGH,
IS YOU HAVE A DIAGRAM.
YEAH. THE DIAGRAM IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN EVERY KIT...
THE DIAGRAM
SHOWS HOW TO DO IT.
...SO THEY CAN MAKE THIS
WITH WHATEVER THEY GOT.
ROBERT, WE GOT
A SPECIAL TREAT FOR YOU
IF YOU WANT TO TRY IT OUT.
I DO WANT TO TRY IT OUT.
OKAY.
SO, WE KNOW YOU LIKE RACING.
OHH. THAT IS COOL.
Corcoran: ADORABLE.
MILO WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE A FRIEND UP HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I CAN'T BUY THE WHOLE KIT,
HUH?
WE DON'T SELL THE KITS,
BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
OUR DIFFERENTIATOR.
Greiner: YOU FIT!
[ IMITATES ENGINE REVVING ]
THERE WE GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S COOL.
YEAH. IT'S A LOT OF FUN.
AND IT BRINGS OUT
THAT CREATIVITY.
HEY, WE'RE GONNA INVITE YOU
TO GO BACK TO FIND MOM NOW.
THANKS, BUD.
BYE, MILO.
BYE.
SEE YA, MILO.
HE'S FLYING OUT.
HOW HARD IS IT
TO TAKE A NORMAL BOX
AND MAKE IT
LIKE THE RACECAR?
Brian:
AS LORI POINTED OUT,
THE INSTRUCTIONS ARE THERE
TO DO A VERY SIMPLE BOX.
I KNOW THESE ARE PAINTED,
BUT WE PREFER THAT THE
KIDS JUST HAVE THE FUN
PLAYING IN THE BOX.
THAT'S WHAT
MAKES US DIFFERENT.
DID YOU
INVESTIGATE THE MODEL
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY CREATED
A PRE-CUT BOX?
BECAUSE IT STILL MAKES IT A LOT
EASIER FOR ME AS A CONSUMER.
AS A DAD,
I-IT'S MUCH MORE WORK.
BUT THAT'S WHAT NICE DADS
DO WITH CHILDREN.
Corcoran:
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO, YOU KNOW.
Cuban: BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT SMART DADS DO?
SMART DADS DON'T SET
A HIGH EXPECTATION
THAT THEY CAN'T FULFILL,
RIGHT?
AFTER SEEING THIS,
THERE'S NO CHANCE
I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT
FOR MY SON JAKE.
HE'S GONNA LOOK AT WHAT I DO,
AND HE'S GONNA LOOK AT THAT...
O'Leary: BUT DID YOU LOOK
AT DOING THAT? DID YOU LOOK --
THAT'S A CHALLENGE.
IF I BUY THIS STICKER KIT,
WHAT AM I GONNA PAY?
IF I BUY A COMPETITOR
THAT INCLUDES THE BOX,
WHAT AM I GOING TO PAY?
UM, WELL,
YOU CAN BUY THAT FOR $7.99.
AND WITH A COMPETITOR THAT HAS
THE BOX ALL CUT OUT FOR YOU,
IT'S FOUR TO SIX TIMES
MORE EXPENSIVE.
Brian: THE VERY FIRST
RETAIL STORE WE WENT INTO --
IT WAS A LOCAL TOY STORE,
INDEPENDENT TOY STORY --
THEY SELL
THOSE TYPES OF KITS.
WHEN WE PUT OUR PRODUCT
OUT THERE,
WE EASILY SOLD 30 OR 40
TO 1 OF WHAT THEY SOLD.
WHAT ARE YOUR TOTAL SALES
OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME?
UM, WELL, WE STARTED THIS
COMPANY EIGHT MONTHS AGO,
AND WE'VE MADE
AROUND $7,500 NOW.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
94 CENTS
FOR THE COMPLETED KIT.
WE WHOLESALE FOR $3.75.
GOT IT.
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING
RIGHT NOW?
UM, WE'RE SELLING
IN 23 RETAIL ACCOUNTS,
MOSTLY INDEPENDENT
TOY STORES,
AND WE'RE ALSO SELLING IT
TO A BOUTIQUE,
A HARDWARE STORE,
AND A BOX STORE.
ARE YOU SELLING THIS ONLINE?
YEAH. THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOW WE STARTED. WE STARTED --
AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF YOUR SALES IS STILL ONLINE?
WELL, WE DO
ABOUT THIRD EQUALLY.
SO, WE HAVE A THIRD
ONLINE SALES,
A THIRD GO INTO
OUR WHOLESALE RETAIL ACCOUNTS,
AND OUR OTHER THIRD WE DID
THROUGH DEAL SITES
WHERE WE WERE
TESTING THE MARKET.
HOW MUCH OF THE BUSINESS
HAVE YOU ACTUALLY DONE
VERSUS JUST YOUR DAD?
UM, I'M INVOLVED
IN EVERY SALE THAT WE DO.
WE'VE GONE TO
ALL THE VENDORS TOGETHER.
HE CHOSE THE PAPER.
HE'S BEEN TO THE PRINTERS.
HE -- THAT'S, YOU KNOW, SORT OF
WHY OUR SALES ARE SO SMALL...
WHAT A GREAT EDUCATION.
...IS I HAVE HIM DO THE SALES,
AND HE'S BEEN AWESOME.
Corcoran:
SO YOU'RE THE REAL BUSINESSMAN,
AND HE'S JUST
TAKING ALL THE CREDIT HERE?
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M DEFINITELY BEHIND IT.
I MEAN, THAT KIND OF GOES INTO
THE STORY OF WHY WE DID THIS.
I -- WHEN NOAH WAS BORN,
I WAS GETTING MY MBA.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO BE AN ENTREPRENEUR.
BUT WHEN I BROUGHT HOME
THAT LITTLE GUY, UM...
YOU KNOW, I-IT'S A FEELING
OF RESPONSIBILITY,
THAT YOU HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL.
AND I NEVER GOT THE CHANCE
TO TAKE THAT -- THAT RISK.
SO, YOU'RE REALLY ALSO LIVING
YOUR OLD DREAM THROUGH HIM.
YEAH. I-I DON'T WANT
TO TEACH HIM
THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE PATH
IN LIFE,
THAT YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW
THIS CORPORATE LADDER.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OWN MY OWN BUSINESS
AND SHOW HIM THAT.
ARE YOU ADVERSE IN OFFERING
A VERSION THAT INCLUDES THE BOX?
BECAUSE THERE IS
SOME SEGMENT OF THE MARKET
THAT FALLS INTO MY CATEGORY
THAT SAYS --
LAZY.
EXACTLY.
"I'M LAZY. I WANT A SOLUTION.
I'M WILLING TO PAY MORE."
BECAUSE I SEE IT, I LOVE IT.
IT'S SIMPLE.
IT FALLS INTO THIS TREND
OF ANTI-ELECTRONICS TOYS.
EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT, LISTEN,
HERE'S WHAT I'LL DO.
I-I LIKE THE STORY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE 35K.
I WANT TO BE A 50/50 PARTNER
WITH ONE CONDITION...
...YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE BOX
AVAILABLE FOR ME TO BUY ONLINE.
YOU DO NOT HAVE
TO PUT IT THROUGH RETAIL.
YOU CAN START WITH THAT.
AND, NOAH,
I GOT THE BAD NEWS FOR YOU --
YOU'VE GOT TO
DROP OUT OF SCHOOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU GOT TO BE FULL-TIME, BUDDY.
THAT'S HOW YOU RUN A BUSINESS.
WHAT GRADE ARE YOU IN, NOAH?
I'M IN 8th GRADE.
IT'S TIME.
SO WHAT? YOU MISS A FEW GRADES.
NOT A PROBLEM.
WELL, UM, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR OFFER, KEVIN.
WE'RE SUPER GRATEFUL
FOR YOU
TO GIVE US THIS CHANCE
AND SEE THIS FUTURE,
AND WE WERE JUST WONDERING
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
GUYS, CONGRATULATIONS.
I THINK YOU'RE SETTING
AN EXAMPLE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT A PARENT AND A CHILD CAN
BOND OVER CREATING A COMPANY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN ADD A LOT OF VALUE
IN THE TOY BUSINESS.
KEVIN'S GOT
A LOT MORE EXPERIENCE.
I THINK HE MADE YOU A VERY FAIR
OFFER THAT I COULDN'T MATCH.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANKS. THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
APPRECIATE YOUR HONESTY.
YOU KNOW, I, UM --
I LOVE WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
THANKS.
I LIKE THE LOGO.
I LOVE THE SIMPLICITY OF IT.
BUT I FEEL THAT IT'S NOT REALLY
SOMETHING SCALABLE,
SO I'M OUT.
WE APPRECIATE THE ADVICE.
YES, THANK YOU.
BUT CALL ME
IN SEVERAL YEARS.
I'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU
INTERN FOR ME.
THERE YOU GO.
Corcoran: GREAT.
COOL.
BARBARA?
HARD ONE.
ROBERT?
Herjavec: I GOT TO TELL YOU,
BEFORE MY SON WAS BORN,
I WAS A LOT LIKE KEVIN.
I HAD NO HAIR.
I HAD A COLD HEART.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A BUCK.
AND THEN MY SON WAS BORN,
AND IT GAVE ME PURPOSE.
I MEAN, I STILL WANTED TO MAKE
A BUCK. DON'T GET ME WRONG.
BUT I WANTED
TO BUILD SOMETHING GREAT.
I THINK
YOU'RE ONTO SOMETHING.
BUT I THINK
YOU'VE GOT TO PACKAGE IT
JUST SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY.
IF YOU CAN SELL
A COMPLETE PACKAGE,
YOU'RE GONNA SELL
A TON OF THESE.
LIKE, A TON OF THESE.
UH-HUH.
SO, ARE YOU WILLING
TO INCREASE
OVER KEVIN'S OFFER
SO THAT WE CAN DO THE --
WELL, I'LL TELL YOU,
I'M NOT SURE YOU WANT TO HAVE
KEVIN AS AN INVESTOR
IN A BUSINESS
THAT APPEALS TO CHILDREN.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT ONE.
KEVIN SCARES CHILDREN.
THE REASON
THAT'S INCORRECT IS I MADE
ALL MY MONEY IN A BUSINESS
THAT APPEALS TO CHILDREN.
MY LARGEST DEAL...
BUT THEY NEVER MET KEVIN.
...WAS FOR $4 BILLION
TO MATTEL.
SO I KNOW YOUR INDUSTRY
PRETTY WELL.
YOU NEED RELATIONSHIPS WITH
TOY COMPANIES' DISTRIBUTION.
GOT THAT. CHECK.
YOU NEED COMMERCIAL PRINTING.
I'M AN INVESTOR IN
A COMMERCIAL PRINTER RIGHT NOW.
YOU'LL PAY FOR YOUR COLLEGE
IF THIS WORKS, NOAH.
BRIAN, NOAH, KEVIN'S IDEAS --
ARE YOU MAKING AN OFFER,
OR WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
KEVIN'S IDEAS ARE WONDERFUL, BUT
WE'RE A FEW YEARS AWAY FROM IT.
LET'S GO, ROBERT.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL DAY.
Greiner:
YEAH, ARE YOU MAKING AN OFFER?
I'M GONNA MAKE
THE SAME OFFER.
THE SAME OFFER AS KEVIN.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $35,000
FOR 50%.
Corcoran:
UM, HERE'S MY THINKING.
UM, YOU REMIND ME, OF COURSE,
OF RYAN FROM RYAN'S BARKERY.
AND HIS BUSINESS IS FLYING.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
A $35,000 OFFER FOR 35%,
ONLY 'CAUSE THE NUMBERS MATCH.
IT SOUNDS COOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SOUNDS COOL.
TWO CONTINGENCIES ARE THIS --
ONE, IF YOU WANT
TO TAKE MY DEAL --
AND YOU'D BE OUT OF YOUR MIND
TO PASS THIS UP --
PLEASE, YOU'VE GOT TO
MAKE THIS THING GIRL-FRIENDLY.
YOU GOT TWO BOYS
ON THE COVER.
THE PILOT'S A MALE, OKAY?
SO YOU HAVE
TO JUST DO A RE-DO
SO YOU CAN OFFER ONLINE
A GIRL AND A BOY'S VERSIONS.
AND YOU HAVE TO USE
AN OPTION ON THAT --
OPTION FOR A BOX.
SO, ON THOSE 2 CONTINGENCIES,
THE OFFER IS $35,000 FOR 35%.
OKAY.
SHE'S OFFERED YOU
$35,000 FOR 35%.
I WAS AT 50%,
SO I'LL UP MY OFFER
TO $50,000 FOR 50%
JUST -- JUST SO THE MATH
IS THE SAME.
AND, BRIAN,
IT SOUNDS COOL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I'M THE FUN SHARK!
THIS IS A FUN TOY.
I'M STAYING
EXACTLY WHERE I STARTED ALL THIS
BECAUSE I ADD THE MOST VALUE.
NO ONE ELSE HERE
HAS SOLD ANYTHING
TO A TOY COMPANY
FOR $4 BILLION.
SO I'M GONNA JUST LEAVE THAT OUT
THERE FOR YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
NOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION,
NOAH. WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
UM, WELL [CHUCKLES]
UH [CHUCKLES]
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
NOAH AND HIS DAD, BRIAN,
HAVE THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR STICKER COMPANY,
PAPER BOX PILOTS.
BARBARA'S OFFER
IS $35,000 FOR 35%.
KEVIN'S IS $35,000 FOR 50%,
AND ROBERT'S
IS $50,000 FOR 50%.
NOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION,
NOAH. WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
UH [CHUCKLES]
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S TOUGH.
BELIEVE ME, LIFE COULD --
LIFE COULD BE WORSE.
SOME OF
THE HARDEST MOMENTS.
VERY FEW PEOPLE THAT COME
IN THE SHARK TANK AT ANY AGE
GET THREE OFFERS LIKE THIS.
YEAH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK,
OR DO YOU HAVE ANY COUNTERS?
SO, WE'D BE CRAZY
NOT TO TRY
TO STEAL A LITTLE INFORMATION
OR KNOWLEDGE FROM YOU.
YOU'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT
THE BOXES.
Corcoran: LET ME --
ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S CHALLENGING FOR US --
LET ME SUGGEST
YOU SHOULD BE CAREFUL.
YOU HAVE THREE ROCK-SOLID OFFERS
ON THE TABLE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THE CLOSE,
YOU WANT TO MOVE TOWARD IT.
SO, ALL I CAN SAY...
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE THE C.E.O.
YOU KNOW, THE DECISION'S
ULTIMATELY YOURS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT'S A TOUGH ONE,
BUT WHAT A WONDERFUL PROBLEM.
DON'T SCREW IT UP.
UM...
[ Chuckling ] I DON'T KNOW.
THESE ARE ALL
REALLY GOOD OPTIONS.
SO [CHUCKLES]
WHICH ONE?
WHO DO YOU THINK
WOULD BE THE BEST MENTOR?
UM [CHUCKLES]
WELL...
I THINK THESE ARE ALL
REALLY GOOD OFFERS.
YOU GUYS ALL BRING A LOT
TO THE TABLE FOR ME.
UM...
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT...
UM, MR. WONDERFUL, KEVIN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DO AN OFFER WITH US?
OH!
WHAT?
WHOO-HOO!
UNBELIEVABLE.
Cuban: YAY! THAT'S A FIRST!
Herjavec: YEAH!
CONGRATULATIONS, NOAH.
HE LOOKS UP TO HIM, OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS GONNA BE A WILD RIDE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
I'M SHOCKED.
GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
TAKE CARE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WHY'D YOU PICK KEVIN? YOU GOT
TO TELL ME. THIS IS AMAZING.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY, 'CAUSE HIS
WAS THE WORST OFFER IN TERMS
OF EQUITY, IN TERMS OF CASH.
AND THE WORST GUY.
Noah: WELL, IT'S REALLY --
KEVIN HAS A TON OF BACKGROUND
IN THE TOY INDUSTRY.
HE'S GOT ALL THE BACKGROUND
THAT WE NEED FOR THIS COMPANY.
VERY THOUGHTFUL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
Greiner: CONGRATS.
GOOD LUCK.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED IT.
YOU OKAY?
YEAH.
YOU DID GOOD.
THAT'S WHAT WE CAME TO DO.
YEAH.
WAS A LOT OF WORK.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU KNOW, I WANTED TO SHOW HIM
THAT IF YOU TAKE RISKS,
YOU KNOW,
BIG THINGS WILL HAPPEN.
I DIDN'T TAKE THAT RISK,
AND I'VE ALWAYS --
[ Voice breaking ]
I'VE ALWAYS REGRETTED IT.
HE DID IT.
HE'S OVERCOME THAT -- THAT FEAR.
Narrator:
LAST SEASON, BRIAN HOOKS
AND HIS DAUGHTERS EMMA AND LILY
STRUCK A DEAL WITH LORI GREINER
FOR THEIR HOMEMADE SCREEN-REPAIR
PRODUCT ScreenMend.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I WOULD WANT 50% OF THE COMPANY.
WE ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
HOW ScreenMend IS DOING NOW.
WATCH THIS.
Emma: LORI ISN'T KIDDING
WHEN SHE SAYS
SHE MOVES AT LIGHTNING SPEED.
WITHIN TWO MONTHS
OF WORKING WITH HER,
WE WERE DOING SHOWS ON QVC.
SO, HERE'S THE PACKAGE.
YOU'RE GETTING TWO IN EACH.
Emma:
WORKING ON QVC WAS ONE OF THE
COOLEST THINGS I'VE EVER DONE.
WITHIN JUST 10 MINUTES ON QVC,
WE SOLD OUT OF ALL 32,000 UNITS.
WE'RE SO EXCITED.
Brian:
GIRLS, HOW ARE WE DOING?
WE GOT A LOT OF ORDERS
TO FILL.
BEFORE WE CAME ON
"SHARK TANK,"
WE'D ONLY DONE
ABOUT $4,000 IN SALES.
SINCE AIRING ON "SHARK TANK"
EIGHT MONTHS AGO,
WE'VE DONE OVER $900,000
IN SALES.
WE DESPERATELY NEED TO GET OUT
OF THE GARAGE
IF WE'RE GONNA KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND.
WE'RE HOPING TO MAKE THE BIG
MOVE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
HI, GUYS!
LORI!
AHH!
Greiner:
I CAME OUT TO LONG ISLAND TODAY
TO BRING BRIAN AND THE GIRLS
SOME BIG NEWS ABOUT ScreenMend.
NEW PACKAGING!
Emma: THEY LOOK FANTASTIC.
WE'RE GONNA BE
IN BED BATH & BEYOND...
NO.
...LOWE'S, ACE, AND HOME DEPOT.
OH, THAT'S AWESOME.
Emma: OH, MY GOODNESS.
Greiner: I THINK ScreenMend
IS GOING TO BE A WILD SUCCESS.
WE'RE GETTING INTO
SO MANY WONDERFUL PLACES.
IT'S EXCITING
FOR THE WHOLE TEAM.
ONE LAST SURPRISE.
YEAH?
I'M FINALLY GONNA
GET YOU OUT OF HERE,
BECAUSE WITHIN WEEKS, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A NEW FACILITY.
SO, GOODBYE, GARAGE.
WE'RE OUT OF THE GARAGE.
THANK GOODNESS.
Emma: LORI'S TAUGHT US THAT
IF WE BELIEVE IN OUR BUSINESS,
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
Lily:
I HOPE TO BE A SHARK.
I THINK IT'S SO COOL,
AND I WANT TO BE JUST LIKE LORI.
YOU ARE A SHARK'S DREAM.
Brian:
AS OUR BUSINESS HAS GROWN,
MY RELATIONSHIP WITH
MY DAUGHTERS HAS ALSO GROWN.
IT'S SUCH A THRILL TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH MY TWO GIRLS.
THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'LL CHERISH FOREVER.
IT'S AN AMERICAN DREAM
COME TRUE.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A SOLUTION
TO A COMMON PROBLEM
ENCOUNTERED WHILE DINING OUT.
Christian:
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS STEVE CHRISTIAN,
PROUDLY FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS.
I'M ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR 25% OF MY BUSINESS --
THE TABLE JACKS.
I'VE BEEN IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY FOR 18 YEARS,
AND I HATE THE SAME THINGS
THAT MY CUSTOMERS DO --
WOBBLY TABLES.
IT'S AN OUTRAGE.
NUMBER-ONE COMPLAINT
IN THE RESTAURANTS.
NORMALLY, WE WOULD GET DOWN
AND PUT PRODUCTS
UNDERNEATH THE TABLE
SO THAT WE COULD
STABLE THEM OUT.
WHAT I'VE INVENTED
IS THE LONGEST-LASTING,
MOST COST-EFFICIENT,
DURABLE STABILIZER EVER MADE...
...THE TABLE JACK.
WITH A PRESS OF THE FOOT,
NOW THE WAIT STAFF --
WATCH CLOSELY, IT WORKS FAST.
WITH A PRESS OF THE FOOT, THE
WAITRESS CAN DROP THE TABLE DOWN
AND STABILIZE THE TABLE,
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS,
INSTEAD OF LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
TO FIX THE FURNITURE.
WELL DONE.
AND HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
BY USING THREE STATIONARY GLIDES
THAT COME IN THE KIT
AND ONE TABLE JACK,
WE CAN STABILIZE THE TABLE
NO MATTER WHICH WAY IT WOBBLES,
LEFT OR RIGHT, FRONT OR BACK,
SIMPLY WITH THE PRESS
OF THE FOOT.
YOU KNOW, SHARKS,
WE'VE BEGUN TO GET INQUIRIES
FROM ALL OVER NORTH AMERICA,
UNITED KINGDOM, JAPAN,
GUAM --
NOT SURE EXACTLY WHERE THAT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IF YOU'D LIKE, I'VE GOT SOME
HERE I CAN PASS OUT TO YOU.
Cuban: PLEASE DO.
Herjavec: SURE.
[ LAUGHING ]
Christian: YOU'RE WELCOME
TO OPEN THE PACKAGES UP.
THANK YOU.
UH-HUH.
LORI.
Cuban: THIS IS ONE OF
THE MYSTERIES OF LIFE.
RIGHT.
THERE'S
"WHERE'S THE OTHER SOCK?"
YEAH.
AND "WHY DO TABLES WOBBLE?"
SO EXPLAIN TO US
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE FLOOR
AND HOW THAT CAUSES IT
TO WOBBLE.
WELL, THERE IS
NO PERFECTLY LEVEL CONCRETE.
IF YOU LOOK
AT THIS WOOD RIGHT HERE,
WHEN THIS WOOD
STARTS SETTLING IN,
IT'S GONNA HAVE
THE HUMPS IN IT.
THAT'S WHAT DROVE ME IN.
ME WALKING INTO MY RESTAURANTS
AND SEEING THIS STUFF
IS WHAT DROVE ME IN
EIGHT YEARS AGO
TO START DESIGNING
THE TABLE JACKS.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES, STEVE?
MY SALES RIGHT NOW,
WITHIN THE TWO-YEAR PERIOD
OF TIME IN BUSINESS,
WE'RE NEARING $200,000
IN SALES.
BUT YOU STARTED IT
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
NO, I STARTED WORKING ON IT
EIGHT YEARS AGO, OKAY?
NOW, LET ME TELL YOU
THE REASON ABOUT THAT.
AGAIN, I OWN THREE RESTAURANTS.
I'M DOING THIS BY MYSELF.
SIX MONTHS AGO,
I SOLD TWO OF MY RESTAURANTS...
YOUR OWN RESTAURANTS.
...FOR A PROFIT.
AND WHEN I PUT THEM
ON THE MARKET, EVERYBODY WAS,
"WHY ARE YOU SELLING THIS
POSITIVE-CASH FLOW BUSINESS?"
THAT I-I PUT FROM THE GROUND UP
WITH 94 EMPLOYEES.
SO, WHY DID YOU SELL THEM?
I SOLD THEM 'CAUSE I SEE
MORE VALUE THAN IN HERE --
O'Leary:
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
I SEE THE OPPORTUNITY,
I SEE THE VALUE.
BETTER THAN
MOST STRAP-ON TABLE LEGS.
GOT IT, ALL THAT.
YES, SIR.
TWO OPTIONS HERE --
ONE IS I RETROFIT
THE WHOLE WORLD OF TABLES
BY FINDING EACH TABLE
ONE AT A TIME.
I DIE OF OLD AGE
BEFORE I EVER MAKE ANY MONEY.
OPTION TWO IS I GO TO
THE MANUFACTURER OF TABLES
AND SAY, "LOOK, STEVE, MY BUDDY
IN HOUSTON, SOLVED THE PROBLEM
"BY HAVING YOU INSTALL THESE
"ON NEW TABLES
EVERY TIME YOU SHIP ONE.
YOU GOT TO PAY ME A ROYALTY
'CAUSE I HAVE A PATENT," RIGHT?
I HAVE A UTILITY PATENT,
A VERY STRONG UTILITY PATENT.
OKAY. IS IT BETTER FOR YOU
TO PUT ALL OF YOUR TIME
GOING TO THE MANUFACTURERS
OF THE TABLES --
NO, BECAUSE
IF THERE'S 9,000 RESTAURANTS
OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS,
RIGHT...
NO.
...AND THEY ALL HAVE
A TABLE,
THEY'RE NOT GONNA IMMEDIATELY
REPLACE THOSE TABLES.
I DON'T CARE.
HE'LL DIE OF OLD AGE
TRYING TO GET SALES
TO ALL THOSE RESTAURANTS.
WELL, WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
YOU WENT TO THE TRADE SHOW
OF ALL THE RESTAURANTS?
BUT THERE'S DISTRIBUTORS
THAT SELL TO ALL OF THEM.
I CAN ANSWER Y'ALL'S QUESTIONS
REAL EASY RIGHT NOW.
WELL, WE'RE -- WE'RE FIGHTING
AMONGST OURSELVES.
I UNDERSTAND.
PLEASE STAY OUT OF IT.
OKAY, GO AHEAD.
WAIT.
THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT
THERE'S -- THERE'S KIND OF
A BINARY DECISION,
BECAUSE TRYING
TO GET TO EVERY TABLE
THAT'S ALREADY IN A RESTAURANT
IS A HUGE HASSLE.
I'M ALREADY DOING IT.
I JUST NOW PUT -- I'VE GOT --
RIGHT NOW, I'VE GOT
PHOENIX, MIAMI, LAS VEGAS, L.A.
FOR THE PAST TWO DAYS,
I BEEN SELLING OUT HERE IN L.A.
AT RODEO BOULEVARD YESTERDAY.
I SOLD AT VENICE BEACH.
I SOLD RESTAURANTS --
WAIT, WAIT.
YOU WENT DOOR-TO-DOOR?
I LOVE IT.
I'VE GOT A GUY IN TEXAS
THAT IS PUTTING 100 TO 300
OF THESE A WEEK ON RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S A VERY, VERY FAMOUS
PIECE OF LITERATURE --
I WANT YOU HEAR ME ON THIS,
STEVE.
OHH.
IT'S A STORY THAT I THINK
WILL DEFINE YOUR BUSINESS.
IT'S GONNA HELP YOU.
WHAT'S IT CALLED?
DANTE. AND HE WROTE
THE VERSIONS OF HELL.
"INFERNO."
THERE'S SEVEN DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF HELL.
THE SEVENTH LEVEL
IS YOU IN A RESTAURANT
CHANGING OUT
THE BOTTOM OF A TABLE.
I DON'T NEED TO HEAR ANY MORE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Greiner:
WHAT DO THEY COST?
NOBODY'S EVEN ASKED YOU
WHAT A PACKAGE COSTS.
Herjavec: YEAH,
WHAT DOES IT COST?
[ CHUCKLES ]
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
SO, IT'S $15.
THIS KIT IS $15?
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT?
$3.65.
STEVE, I WORKED
IN A LOT OF BARS,
AND WE USED
SUGAR PACKETS.
THEM SUGAR PACKS
COST ME MONEY.
THAT'S WHY
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
BUT I'M LISTENING TO YOU,
AND I'M NOT CLEAR.
HOW DO YOU MAKE IT BIGGER?
YOU COULD TALK A DOG OFF
A MEAT WAGON, I'M TELLING YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CAN IT WORK
ON A FOUR-LEGGED TABLE
OR ONLY WITH
THIS KIND OF A BASE?
WELL, IT'S A FOUR-LEGGED --
NO, NO, I'M TALKING ABOUT
FOUR SEPARATE LEGS.
IT DOESN'T WORK. IT HAS TO HAVE
THIS CONFIGURATION HERE.
WELL, THE FOUR-LEGGED TABLE
IS -- IS GONNA BE DIFFERENT.
SO, NO.
THAT IS -- THAT IS --
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE ONLY ON THE --
YEAH. GOT IT.
GOT IT. NO.
WAS THAT A NO?
THAT WAS A NO, I THINK.
WELL, I MEAN,
I COULD MOUNT --
I-I COULD D-DESIGN IT
TO FIT TO THIS.
OKAY. OKAY.
HERE'S WHAT I'M THINKING, OKAY?
MM-HMM.
I WAS WORKING AS A WAITRESS
WHEN I GOT MY $1,000 LOAN
TO START MY BUSINESS.
AND THAT WAS
A CONSTANT PROBLEM.
MM-HMM.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT WAS KEY TO MAKING THE TIPS.
I WOULD PRETEND THE TABLE
WAS A PROBLEM AND BEND ON OVER.
OH, YOU WOULD
HIT ON THE CUSTOMERS?
NO, LET ME TELL YOU,
MY TIPS WERE THROUGH THE ROOF.
I JUST WOULDN'T --
NOW, DO YOU REALLY THINK
THAT WAS BECAUSE OF THE TABLE
OR WAS BECAUSE YOU BENDING OVER?
NO, I HAD A NICE BUTT.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
"WHOOPS!"
BUT IF NOT
FOR THAT LITTLE GIMMICK,
I COULD'VE NEVER GOTTEN
THE $1,000.
I COULD'VE NEVER BUILT
MY BILLION-DOLLAR BUSINESS.
NONE OF THAT
WOULD'VE HAPPENED.
IN PRINCIPLE,
I CAN'T GO IN.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M OUT.
IT'S REALLY CLEVER.
IT REALLY WORKS, BUT JUST ON
ONE TYPE OF TABLE.
YOU'VE GONE
KNOCKING ON DOORS,
BUT IN ALL THESE YEARS,
YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT BIG OF SALES.
MM-HMM.
AND I THINK IT MIGHT BE
BECAUSE YOU CREATED
SOMETHING VERY CLEVER
FOR A PROBLEM
THAT NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE HAVE
WHERE THEY WANT
TO PAY FOR IT.
MM-HMM.
I DON'T SEE A BIG MARKET FOR IT.
I'M OUT.
GREAT INVENTION.
IT OBVIOUSLY, CERTAINLY WORKS.
IT'S GONNA BE
A LONG, LONG JOURNEY
TO GET IT INTO
A LOT OF RESTAURANTS
WHERE YOU CAN MAKE MONEY,
AND THEN I, AS AN INVESTOR,
CAN MAKE MONEY. I...
MM-HMM.
I DON'T WANT TO BE THERE.
I WORKED IN A RESTAURANT.
I SAID I WOULD NEVER GO
BACK THERE IN ANY WAY. I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SO, MARK, YOU'RE THE LAST SHARK
THAT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY.
I'M THE LAST SHARK?
OH, MAN!
AND YOU'RE FROM TEXAS.
THROW THIS GUY A BONE.
GIVE HIM $100,000, PLEASE.
I BEG YOU.
I'M SO CLOSE TO
GETTING OVER THE HILL ON THIS,
'CAUSE ONCE WE GET -- WE'VE
GOTTEN SOME OF THE BIG PEOPLE.
I NEED TO GET PAST
THAT GATEKEEPER
AND WHERE THEY CAN SEE THEM.
'CAUSE THEM PEOPLE
SITTING UP IN THAT OFFICE --
THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE
WOBBLY TABLES
IN THE RESTAURANTS.
THEY'RE SO BUSY
DOING OTHER THINGS.
TO GET THIS THING TO GOING,
IT'S NOT GONNA TAKE THAT MUCH.
STEVE, LOOK.
I LOVE YOU, RIGHT?
ANYBODY WHO GOES DOOR-TO-DOOR
IS JUST CLOSE TO MY HEART,
'CAUSE I GREW UP
SELLING MAGAZINES DOOR-TO-DOOR.
AND IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO GO DOOR-TO-DOOR,
YOU CAN SELL ANYTHING.
ANYTHING.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS,
I'M NOT READY TO INVEST $100,000
TO -- TO BE A PARTNER.
I'M NOT READY
TO MAKE THE COMMITMENT
OR -- OR THE INVESTMENTS.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, STEVE.
HEY, THANK YOU, SIR.
LOT OF FUN.
I LOVED HIM.
Christian: I HOPE THAT WHEN
THE SHARKS GO TO DINNER TONIGHT,
I HOPE THAT THEIR TABLE
DOES WOBBLE,
OR ANY OTHER TIME THEY GO,
'CAUSE THEY WILL BE THANKING
TABLE JACKS
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A UNIQUE WAY TO SMELL FRESH.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS BEN KUSIN.
AND I'M HIS BROTHER,
ERIC KUSIN.
OUR COMPANY'S NAME'S
REVIVER,
AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR $150,000
FOR A 5% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
THE SNIFF TEST --
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
THIS THING --
[ BOTH SNIFF ]
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
SMOKE, SWEAT, FOOD ODORS
CAN LEAVE YOUR CLOTHES
SMELLING -- WELL, NOT SO FRESH.
AND WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU FAIL THE SNIFF TEST?
YOU'RE LEFT
WITH NO OTHER OPTION
OTHER THAN TO RUN HOME
AND CHANGE CLOTHES
OR JUST LIVE
WITH YOUR STINKY SELF.
[ CHUCKLES ]
UNTIL NOW.
INTRODUCING REVIVER
CLOTHING SWIPES,
THE GROUNDBREAKING
INVENTION
FOR INSTANT AND ON-THE-GO
CLOTHING FRESHNESS.
OUR REVOLUTIONARY TECHNOLOGY
ALLOWS YOU TO SWIPE
A DRY LAYER OF ODOR-FIGHTING
FORMULATION ONTO YOUR OUTFIT
TO KEEP YOU FRESH
BETWEEN WASHES.
THINK OF REVIVER AS BREATH
MINTS, BUT FOR YOUR CLOTHES.
NOW WE'RE READY
TO BRING REVIVER TO THE WORLD.
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WANTS TO JOIN US
IN THE FRESHNESS
REVOLUTION?
SO, WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO SHOW YOU HOW REVIVER WORKS.
LORI, IF YOU DON'T MIND COMING
UP FOR A QUICK DEMONSTRATION.
A LOT OF US
ARE EATING ON THE RUN NOWADAYS,
LEAVING OUR CLOTHES SMELLING
A LOT LIKE WHAT WE JUST ATE.
TO IMITATE THAT, WE'VE BEEN
LETTING THIS SHIRT MARINATE
IN SOME BURGERS AND FRIES
AND SOME OTHER FRIED FOOD.
YOU CAN GUARANTEE
IT DOESN'T PASS THE SNIFF TEST.
EWW! WHOA.
YEAH.
INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO RUN HOME
AND, FRANKLY,
JUST BURN THAT SHIRT,
BEN'S GONNA SHOW YOU
HOW EASY IT IS
TO REVIVE YOUR SHIRT
WITH REVIVER.
YEAH. SO, I JUST, RIGHT HERE,
SLIDE IT ONTO MY FINGERS,
SWIPE GENTLY
THE WHITE LAYER
AGAINST MY CLOTHES
AND EVEN MY HAIR --
IT ACTUALLY
HELPS FRESHEN YOUR HAIR.
SO, IF YOU NOTICE,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS,
IT'S A CLEAR LAYER
OF ODOR-FIGHTING FORMULATION.
SO, IF YOU
JUST WANT TO SMELL...
MM-HMM.
JUST LIKE THAT.
AND IT'S REUSABLE.
LORI, DID IT WORK?
IS IT BETTER?
IT IS BETTER.
Ben: SO NOW, SHARKS, WE'D LIKE
YOU TO SEE FOR YOURSELVES
WHAT THIS REVOLUTIONARY
TECHNOLOGY IS ALL ABOUT.
SO, ERIC, IF YOU COULD
HAND OUT SOME SWIPES.
EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF OUR PRODUCTS HERE,
IF YOU JUST WANT TO
GRAB ONE OF THOSE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP, LORI.
SORRY TO PUT YOU THROUGH THAT.
NO, IT WAS GOOD. I LIKED IT.
MR. WONDERFUL.
Herjavec: HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THE IDEA?
Eric: IT ACTUALLY WAS
ONE OF THOSE PRODUCTS
THAT WAS GENUINELY
BORN OUT OF NEED.
I HAD, UH,
HAD A CIGARETTE,
AND I WAS GOING BACK INTO WORK
FOR A REALLY IMPORTANT MEETING,
AND I REALIZED
THAT MY CLOTHES SMELLED.
SO I WENT
TO A CONVENIENCE STORE,
AND I NOTICED THERE WAS
A LOT OF OPTIONS FOR MY MOUTH.
THERE WAS BREATH MINTS,
BREATH STRIPS,
BREATH SPRAY,
THERE WAS GUM.
BUT THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
FOR MY CLOTHES.
AND IT HIT ME
AT THAT MOMENT.
I WAS LIKE, "WOW, THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE." SO
THAT'S WHEN I STARTED --
IS IT SOMETHING LIKE FEBREZE,
THOUGH? I'M JUST CURIOUS.
LIKE, IS IT
THAT TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY,
OR IS THIS DIFFERENT?
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT.
WE HAVE --
I HAVE THREE CO-INVENTORS
ON THIS THAT ARE SCIENTISTS
THAT HAVE HELPED
WITH THIS PRODUCT.
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON IT?
WE'RE PATENT-PENDING.
PATENT-PENDING.
WE FEEL REALLY STRONG
ABOUT IT.
AND HOW MUCH
HAVE YOU SPENT SO FAR?
ON WHICH ASPECT?
ALL OF IT.
Cuban: ALL OF IT.
YEAH, WE'VE INVESTED A LOT
OF MONEY INTO THE COMPANY.
WHAT'S A LOT OF MONEY?
RIGHT. SO,
WE HAVE A FAMILY INVESTOR
WHO'S SPENT $2 MILLION
ON THE COMPANY SO FAR.
O'Leary: $2 MILLION?
Cuban: $2 MILLION?
Herjavec: WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
ON THE BOOKS,
THIS IS EARNEST CAPITAL.
ERIC, HANG ON.
YEAH, ROBERT.
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT
$2 MILLION.
YEAH. WE HAVE $2 MILLION.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE --
FROM A FAMILY FRIEND.
FROM A FAMILY MEMBER.
IT'S OUR FATHER WHO'S THE
EQUITY PARTNER IN THE BUSINESS.
OH, OKAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALE--
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES --
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES NOW?
IN UNDER 10 MONTHS,
WE'VE DONE $510,000 IN SALES.
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING IT NOW?
THE FIRST PERSON TO SEE IT,
ODDLY ENOUGH,
HAPPENED TO BE A BUYER AT PETCO.
AM I JUST MASKING THE ODOR,
OR I'M ACTUALLY
REDUCING WHATEVER...
Greiner:
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
...THAT'S CREATING THE ODOR?
IN OTHER WORDS,
IF THERE'S A BACTERIA
THAT'S ROTTING ON YOUR DOG,
IS THIS KILLING THE BACTERIA,
OR AM I JUST MASKING IT?
IT'S MASKING THE ODOR,
WHICH --
Corcoran: FOR HOW LONG
WILL IT MASK THE ODOR?
Eric: IT REALLY SUSTAINS.
THEY TESTED THE CLOTHES
AN HOUR LATER -- NO PROBLEM.
SO, OUT OF THE $500,000,
IS IT ALL PETCO?
NO.
SO, PETCO'S ALMOST HALF
OF OUR BUSINESS SO FAR.
HOW MANY LOCATIONS?
ALL OF THEM.
UH, 1,200
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND WHAT'S THE AVERAGE COST
OF A UNIT?
IT'S 55 -- 55 CENTS,
AND EACH ONE RETAILS FOR $2.99.
Greiner: COSTS YOU 55 CENTS.
YEAH. REUSABLE.
EACH WIPE, EACH PET WIPE,
IS $2.99.
CORRECT.
SO, YEAH.
WHAT ARE YOU PROJECTING
FOR SALES FOR THE NEXT YEAR?
WE, UH --
FOR THE NEXT 12 MONTHS,
WE HAVE $4 MILLION
IN PROJECTED SALES.
PROJECTING ON WHAT?
BASED ON WHAT?
WHOA.
AND I UNDERSTAND
IT'S A LEAP.
OKAY. OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A LEAP.
AND I --
$500,000 TO $1.5 MILLION
IS A LEAP.
$500,000 TO $4 MILLION...
I-I REALLY GOT TO FOCUS
ON A COUPLE OF THINGS HERE
THAT NOBODY'S TOUCHED ON,
BUT THANK GOODNESS I'M HERE.
YOU'RE OFFERING ME
5% FOR $150,000.
THAT IMPUTES A VALUE
OF $3 MILLION.
AND YOU HAVE TAKEN $2 MILLION
FROM YOUR DAD, RIGHT?
WHAT DOES YOUR DAD DO
THAT HE CAN AFFORD
TO GIVE YOU $2 MILLION?
OKAY, SO, WE'RE -- WE --
WE'RE VERY LUCKY
TO COME FROM A SUCCESSFUL
ENTREPRENEURIAL FAMILY.
MY DAD'S
A SELF-MADE ENTREPRENEUR.
RIGHT.
HE STARTED A COMPANY
WHICH IS NOW CALLED GameStop,
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL RETAIL --
OH, YEAH.
OH, HE'S THE GameStop FOUNDER?
FAMILIAR WITH GameStop.
WOW.
Herjavec:
YOU'VE USED THE $2 MILLION.
THE $2 MILLION'S GONE.
CORRECT.
WHY DO YOU NEED
THE $150,000?
WE NEED YOU GUYS.
WE HAVE A BIG MEETING
WITH THE WORLD'S LARGEST
RETAILER IN AUGUST.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION
WHEN WE'RE SITTING THERE.
O'Leary: LOOK,
YOU CAN MENTION THE NAME.
IS IT WALMART?
Both: IT IS WALMART.
ARE YOU GONNA DO A TEST, OR ARE
YOU GONNA ROLL ALL THE STORES?
I THINK IF YOU WERE THERE --
IT WOULD CHANGE
IF YOU WERE THERE.
IF YOU'RE THERE, HOPEFULLY,
WE'D GET INTO ALL STORES.
THIS IS SOME-- HE CAN MAKE
SOME INTRODUCTIONS.
YOUR DAD IS IN YOUR CORNER.
WHEN YOU'RE AT A MEETING
WITH WALMART, THEY DON'T CARE.
Cuban: I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD PRODUCT.
BUT FIRST,
YOU'RE NOT A TECHNOLOGY.
YOU'RE NOT A TECHNOLOGY
ANY MORE THAN TALCUM POWDER.
YOU'RE CALLING THIS
A TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW YOU PLACATE DAD.
I-I'M SORRY, I DON'T SEE --
IT'S A FORMULATION.
IT'S A FORMULATION
THAT WORKS.
IN MACHINERY --
WE ACTUALLY SPENT $150,000
IN CUSTOM MACHINERY.
THAT DOESN'T
MAKE IT A TECHNOLOGY.
AND YOU ONLY CALL IT
A TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO GO TO DAD
AND SAY, "DEAR DAD,
WE HAVE A TECHNOLOGY."
IT'S NOT A TECHNOLOGY.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN.
BUT ERIC AND BEN
HAVE TURNED MARK OFF
WITH THEIR SPIN ON THE COMPANY.
Cuban: I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A GOOD PRODUCT.
BUT FIRST,
YOU'RE NOT A TECHNOLOGY.
I-I GUESS I MIGHT --
I-I UNDERSTAND.
I GUESS I UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY IN REGARD
TO THE TECHNOLOGY ASPECT IS...
UH, WE JUST STARTED THINKING
OF OURSELVES AS TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE THE MANUFACTURERS
ARE TELLING US WHAT THIS CAN DO.
IT CAN BE
A MOSQUITO REPELLENT.
YEAH, BUT WAIT. WAIT.
GREAT!
SO CAN TALCUM POWDER!
IT CAN DO
A LOT OF THINGS, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW WHAT'S FANTASTIC,
THOUGH?
GUYS -- Shh.
I'M SORRY, MARK.
I APOLOGIZE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SORRY TO HEAR THAT, MARK.
DOES IT BOTHER YOU --
AND TELL ME IF MY MATH IS WRONG,
BECAUSE I'M STILL STRUGGLING
WITH SOMETHING --
YOUR NUMBER-ONE TEST
WAS PETCO.
YOU'VE DONE $250,000 THERE
IN 1,200 STORES.
YOU'VE SOLD, IN 10 MONTHS,
$208 PER STORE.
THAT'S LIKE 20 BUCKS.
Greiner: BEN,
LET ME ASK A QUESTION.
DO YOU AGREE
THAT 20 BUCKS A MONTH
IS -- IS LIKE RAT POOP
TO A BUYER?
HE WOULDN'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
NOT AT SCALE. NOT AT ALL.
THAT'S NOT -- SO --
YOU'RE ON YOUR WAY
TO GETTING DE-LISTED THERE.
YOU NEED MUCH MORE IN SALES
TO JUSTIFY
A $3 MILLION VALUATION.
THAT IS THE REASON I'M OUT. I
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE REST OF IT.
WOW.
I FEEL VERY BADLY
SAYING THIS TO YOU,
BUT I,
AS A MATTER OF PRINCIPLE,
DON'T INVEST
IN RICH KIDS' BUSINESSES.
NOW, THIS IS SAD, BECAUSE
IT'S A PREJUDICE FOR YOU.
COMING FROM MY BACKGROUND,
THE BEST PRIVILEGE I HAD
WAS I HAD 1,000 BUCKS
TO TRY TO MAKE A RUN WITH
THAT I BORROWED, BEGGED,
AND STEAL FOR.
YOU GOT TO DO
EVERYTHING IN YOUR POWER,
'CAUSE THAT CLOCK IS TICKING,
TICK, TICK, TICK, TICK, TICK,
AND YOU'RE RUNNING OUT OF GAS.
YOU WANT TO KNOW SOMETHING?
THE BIGGEST LIABILITY YOU HAVE
IS YOU'VE GOT A RICH DAD.
AND THAT'S NOT EVEN YOUR FAULT
AS AN ENTREPRENEUR.
BECAUSE I HAVE WATCHED --
ALL OF MY GREAT ENTREPRENEURS
THAT I'VE INVESTED IN
HAVE BEEN DIRT-POOR.
AND I LOVE THEM
POOR, HUNGRY, AND DESPERATE.
SO I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S A BUNCH OF CRAP.
YOU THINK SO?
BECAUSE WHAT SHE
BASICALLY SAID IS
MY KIDS WILL NEVER BE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE I'M -- I'M WELL-OFF.
THAT'S A BUNCH OF CRAP.
SUCCESS DOESN'T GIVE A DAMN
WHO YOUR DAD IS.
YOU DID SOMETHING.
REGARDLESS
OF WHERE YOU CAME FROM,
YOU GOT $500,000 IN SALES.
ABSOLUTELY.
Greiner: I DON'T CARE
IF YOUR DAD WAS RICH OR POOR
OR ANY OF THAT.
WHEN YOU WALKED IN HERE,
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
"CHA-CHING-A-LING-A-DING-DONG."
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE THIS IS
A REALLY GOOD PRODUCT.
AND SO I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
WOW.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $150,000,
BUT I WANT 15%.
HEY, SHOULD WE GO...
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OFFER.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
BUT THEY DON'T NEED IT.
NO. WE'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO
JUST -- IF YOU DON'T MIND --
BARBARA, I'M SORRY,
WE'RE HERE -- WE'RE HERE
WITH TRUE INTENTIONS.
YOU SAID YOU WANTED
A STRATEGIC PARTNER.
AND TO ME,
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN HAVE
ALL THE MONEY IN THE WORLD,
BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT CONNECTIONS
AND YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT STRATEGIC PARTNER,
YOU COULD GET IN A FEW STORES
AND THEN FIZZLE.
ROBERT, IS --
I-I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
I KNOW WHERE YOU STAND.
LOOK, YOU -- YOU CAN'T ARGUE
WITH SALES.
HALF A MILLION IN SALES
IN 10 MONTHS,
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary: ROBERT,
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
DO YOU WANT TO
INVEST IN THIS OR NOT?
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 10%.
HE JUST CUT YOUR VALUATION
IN HALF.
WELL,
IT'S BETTER THAN LORI'S.
I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT YOU NEED TV,
YOU NEED QVC.
I THINK WE CAN TAKE THIS
TO THE TOP.
QVC,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO LORI,
IS ONE AVENUE. IT'S FANTASTIC.
I'M IN WALMART.
I'M IN HOME DEPOT.
I'M IN WALGREENS.
I'M IN EVERYWHERE, EVERY MAJOR.
BUT SHE-- SHE'S GIVING YOU...
BED BATH --
...AN UNDER-A-MILLION-DOLLAR
VALUATION.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
LORI, WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
JOIN OUR FRESHNESS FAMILY.
CHA-CHING!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YAY.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
I LIKE IT.
I THINK THIS IS GONNA BLOW UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
LORI.
I REALLY DO.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
ROBERT, REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR OFFER.
Ben:
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD LUCK.
TO BE RICH KIDS,
YOU HAVE TO BE RICH.
WE'RE NOT RICH,
SO RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
THAT'S AN UNFAIR
CHARACTERIZATION
OF HOW THEY MADE IT OUT TO BE
BECAUSE OF OUR FATHER'S SUCCESS.
NOW, WILL WE BE RICH?
I THINK WITH LORI ON BOARD,
WE'RE ON OUR WAY.
BUT UNTIL THEN, I'D HOLD OFF
ON CALLING US RICH KIDS.